hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan this is a
special edition brought to you by Telus
ox business they've launched a new
contest with the global mail where
they're giving away a hundred thousand
dollars to a Canadian entrepreneur if
you want to interview a chance to win
you can go to the global mail com / the
challenge so today I'm going to answer
question from one of our Telus talks
business readers Liz who wants to start
a business but is scared and one of my
advice on how to get started and
overcome that fear so there's a couple
things for you to keep in mind the first
why you starting your business and I try
to get excited about it so why is it
that you want to start that business
what are you really excited about what
are you passionate about who do you
think you can help where do you thinking
that a lot of value to and let that fuel
your excitement right you should be
excited to wake up every day and want to
do something with your business if it's
something just to make money and doesn't
really interest you then maybe you
should look for a different opportunity
that you can get more excited about so
if you look at every famous successful
entrepreneur they had that burning fire
inside of them to want to start that
business because they had a passion for
what they were doing so let that feel
you and let that get you excited and
want to want to move forward with your
company the next thing to kind of reduce
the the risk and the fear is start part
time you don't have to start full-time
quit whatever job and income source you
have right now start on a part-time
basis start for one hour a day you know
start on a small scale let momentum
build up let you you know start to get
excited again about why you're doing
this business let some customers upset
you start coming in start talking to
people you know get that momentum going
with your business it's better to do
something on an ongoing basis even if
it's as as little as one hour day just
to start building up some momentum with
your company and that fuels you to want
to keep going so you don't have to start
full time start part-time talk to your
customers get close to them make sure
you're building a product or service
that really help solve their problems
and continue to building around that the
last part again to also make sure you're
reducing your risk is don't spend money
in till you're making money whatever
business you're in usually don't have to
spend a lot of mine
to get it started and you can start
especially if you're doing a service
type of based business the only amount
that you have to invest is your time and
I encourage entrepreneurs not to focus
on how much resources you have but how
resourceful you can be and that's going
to be what determines your success so
don't start spend a lot of money that's
what's scary right you're going to lose
whatever nest egg you built up for
yourself spend a lot of time building it
up talking to customers getting close to
them understanding their pain point
seeing where you might be able to help
and then as money starts coming in from
small sales that you're able to make
then you can invest that back into your
business and you have cash flow to start
supporting your company and eventually
you can get to the point where you can
quit whatever job you have whatever
other income sources you have to take up
your time to focus on your own company
so get excited about what you're doing
let that fuel you let that kind of get
you going get your juices pumped up to
want to get that business launched
remember you don't have to start full
time you can start on a part-time basis
and don't spend a lot of money don't
spend until you're making money try to
focus on making that money first before
you start letting the flow out of your
wall because anybody can spend but not
everybody can earn so that should be
your focus hopefully you guys like the
video if you did please give it a thumbs
up if you have other questions or other
comments for Liz it'd be great to see it
in the comments below and again if
you're Canadian entrepreneur who wants
to enter the contest to win a hundred
thousand dollars go to the bill mail com
/ the challenge I'm one of the judges so
hopefully we'll see you there thank you
and stay tuned for next episode
you